let's deal with the sick care system
that we live in today can you kind of
summarize it because i mean i've seen
you talk about a lot quite a few times
there's probably people watching today
that don't know what that means but we
live in a medical medical care system
today in the west that you've loosely
defined as sick care what do you mean by
that
yeah so again man honor be with you here
today um sick care the best way to
define it you know other people have
defined it as illness medicine but
essentially our entire medical care
program system wherever you are in the
world
is based on the idea that the
you know medical system the doctors and
then of course the people that they're
attached to which would be the big
pharma and medicines are treating
symptoms
they're not actually addressing the root
cause so majority of people in the world
today have you know insurance through
their job or through their benefits or
whatever it is and they go to the doctor
when they get a sniffle or they get sick
or you know maybe they are seriously
injured
and they have a co-payment and you know
they go through the front desk
and you know it's one of those things
and then they sit there and they wait
and then the doctor comes and basically
says what's going on they get five
minutes with the doctor if they're lucky
and then the doctor writes some scripts
for this this and this right now look we
can put that into the world of like men
the average guy today who's 40 years old
or even younger now goes to the doctor
he's like doc i feel like i'm dead
tired at one o'clock two o'clock in the
afternoon i want to go home and take a
nap what does it matter with me and the
doc looks at them and says
um you know i can write you a script for
you know because obviously this dude is
probably depressed i can write you a
script for an ssri
and the guy is probably complaining of
sexual dysfunction right because we know
what this is this is a testosterone
deficiency so the doc writes him a
script for a erectile dysfunction
medication which again
as you know richard is not addressing
the root cause
of his symptomology which is likely a
testosterone deficiency now i'll take it
one step further let's say the doctor is
smart and says i'm gonna order labs for
you
let's check your testosterone
so then a week later he gets his labs
back he comes back in with the doctor
meanwhile he's being billed for these
appointments and the doctor looks at his
labs and his labs are you know in the
normal range of testosterone but
obviously very very low and he says oh
you're fine
your testosterone's healthy you're good
you know you're in this defined
compressed laboratory range
and you're okay and so now the guy
thinks he doesn't have a symptom of or
isn't testosterone deficient which isn't
true
and has two drugs that he's going to be
using again the ssri and the erectile
dysfunction drug which will eventually
make his symptomology again of
testosterone deficiency not diagnosed
worse
so it's the you know the tail
dragging the dog here it is a situation
where most of these guys never ever get
healthy
or the proper advice unless they're
listening to people like you or me yeah
and that's just one example of
hundreds maybe even thousands right like
they're like oh yeah the entire medical
system and i've experienced this too
like the entire medical system is
designed and even big pharma is is
designing the entire system to keep you
on their subscription system like even
right now
and um i mean we'll loosely talk about
the beer bug and what's going on with um
vaccination and stuff like that but
if it walks like a duck and quacks like
a duck i call it a duck right and what
i'm looking at right now in this system
is a
vaccination protocol by big pharma to
get your immune system on
their payroll rather than you
maintaining your own i mean is that
something that you would agree with or
disagree with no 100 agreement and i
wanted to break this news for you i
didn't even tell you that i was going to
do this so hopefully this doesn't get us
deleted but i actually have 10 people
right now in europe who i
mentor slash
follow me however you want to look at it
and all of them have had their lab work
done in the last two months and they're
all because again they're in the
european union they're fully bead
and every single one of them is like you
and me they work out they eat healthy
they train
none of them are on uh therapeutic
testosterone which obviously we can talk
about if we want but every single one of
them since getting this second you know
whatever
dude their t values have plummeted i
mean
shock and all type levels right like all
these guys are like dude what's going on
what happened to me i'm not one of them
ever thought of that you know because
they're not in that path but i was like
uh well let's you know process some
elimination let's figure it out you know
are you
using sarms or some like that
and none of these guys are and then
they're like you know i'm like have you
been
beat and they're like yeah i'm in the
european union you have to be you can't
go anywhere if you're not right
so again 10 people
last two months you know do i have
scientific inquiry proving that that's
the case no but i mean do i have
obviously you know empirical data that
tells me that something isn't right
yes so my point and why i'm telling you
this is this is going to become a much
bigger problem richard in the next few
years yeah we'll see how all that
unfolds i mean time will tell with that
one
you